[Music]
numerous rumors about marvel spider-man
3 have been circulating in the movie
community for some
time now there's talk of a gigantic
multiverse with appearances by
andrew garfield and toby maguire
spiderman and benedict cumberbatch as
doctor strange
marvel now seems to be taking the
counter-offensive given the potentially
leaked information
deliberately throwing up images with
fake movie titles across the cast's
social media accounts
on tom holland's instagram for example
you get to see a picture of him with his
coasters and daiya and jacob babylon and
the title
spider-man phone home on zanaya's
instagram page
it's the same thing a picture of the
three actors with the caption
spider-man homeslice on jacob battle on
site you can probably guess
an image in the title are also revealed
here were the title
spider-man homewrecker while the images
are most likely indeed from the film
the titles are of course fictional so
marvel is cleverly diverting the focus
from potentially initial clues regarding
dr rock or electro to the already
confirmed appearances of the three main
characters
this probably also goes hand in hand
with tom holland's confusing statement
that he knew nothing about garfield's of
mcguire's involvement as we already
reported in our news a few weeks ago
on wednesday though the whole thing was
solved to the delight of many fans
in a short clip after jokingly taking
aim and tom holland's tendency for
spoilers
the correct title has been revealed
spider-man
no way home the third spider-man part is
expected to be released on december 17
2021 a few days ago disney announced a
whole range of new projects to be
released in the
upcoming months one of the highlights is
the clone wars spin-off star wars bad
badge
the story is said to be about the
5-member elite unit clone force 99 who
don't always act according to the rules
and therefore often end up in absurd
situations each of them also has special
abilities that perfectly complement
those of their team partners
combined this results in a pretty
battle-hardened squad that won't back
down from
any challenge star wars bad badge is
scheduled for release
on may 4th on disney plus so you'll be
able to watch it soon
also of course marvel is fairly present
in disney's announcement so among other
releases
falcon and the winter soldier will
arrive on march 19th
as well as loki on june 11th another
highlight is the series sequel to the
popular animated thumb monsters
inc called monsters at work on july 2nd
on march 4th the previous streaming
service cbs all
access will be replaced by paramount
plus included are of course the major
cinema films but in contrast to walnut
brothers counterpart hbo max paramount
is pursuing a different strategy
movies are not to appear on the same day
but 30 to 45 days
after their actual release included are
titles such as a quiet place 2 and
mission impossible 7.
another special feature is a deal
between mgm
and paramount that for instance includes
the release of the new bond film
no time to die also featured is the new
star trek series strange new worlds and
fans of the halo franchise can soon
expect a series based on the games
as well paramount parent company viacom
cbs also owns networks such as showtime
nickelodeon and comedy central so you
can look forward to both familia
and new content here too since the end
of 2014 work has already been underway
on the new dc film
the flash many years followed without
significant progress and especially some
unsuccessful staff decisions a few days
ago
producer barbara muschietti finally
uploaded the first set picture of a
large warehouse with her husband
it director andy muschietti in the
foreground
shortly after the next piece of positive
news came out
as they finally found an actress for the
new supergirl
namely sasha cal she will thereby
supersede melissa benoist who played
supergirl in the flash series for six
seasons the long-awaited reboot of the
dc superhero universe is finally getting
the ball rolling as the flash is
supposed to be the kickoff for the
multiverse concept
similar to that of the mcu along with
this comes an appearance by both
michael keaton and ben affleck who will
stand in front of the camera together as
the batman
currently there is also rumor that danny
devito will take on the role of oswald
cobblepot aka
penguin we are eagerly awaiting further
cast editions and the apparent
approaching shooting start
and we're looking forward to the release
of the flash on november 4th
2022 to the excitement of many fans it
was announced a few days ago that the
original creators of the avatar animated
series
will soon be producing new content
avatar studios has been created together
with nickelodeon and has a tweet from
nickelodeon indicates
several adventures around the
protagonist and a plan for the future
an official press release states that
several series and movies based on the
world of avatar the last airbender and
the legend of korra
are being planned as well up front are
the avatar creators and producers
michael dimartino and brian konietzko
it has not yet been revealed what role
the comics which have been expanding the
avatar verse for quite some time will
play in this
at the same time the live action
adaption is still
in the works at netflix the martino and
kaniesco dropped out of the project some
time ago however
and there are probably only a few fans
who are seriously looking forward to it
in any case
we are excited to see which kind of
projects avatar studios will tackle
and we'll keep you up to date as usual
things are going pretty well for tom
holland at the moment the third
spiderman movie is coming out soon he's
also starring in the upcoming uncharted
and in addition to all the a-list movies
he can also play more serious roles for
example in
cherry and the devil all the time but
obviously it didn't just come to him
because as the 24 year old recently
revealed in an interview with backstage
he even auditioned for a role in
disney's star wars trilogy
if a rather funny mishap hadn't happened
to him back then we would probably see
tom holland in the role of the
stormtrooper and later resistance
fighter
finn today he's said to have mastered
the first casting rounds
brilliantly but when he then auditioned
for a scene with a woman who made droid
noises he just couldn't keep himself
from laughing
needless to say he didn't get the part
and john boyega
beat out the others do you think tom
holland would have fit the role of finn
as well as boyega or do you think it's a
good thing that he didn't get the role
in the end
feel free to let us know your opinion in
the comments
[Music]
huh